Matt Damon he is back as Jason Bourne
and a big part of the movie takes place
in Las Vegas so that's where I joined
Matt Ferraro an exclusive little poker
tournament now here's the big question
who do you think walked away the big
winner so what are we what are we
playing here Texas hold well this is fun
this is the latest in an interview we'll
do an interview we'll play cards we'll
see what you really got
so what was it like going back to boy it
was fantastic and it did so much for my
life and my career to really changed
everything so it's about whether we can
do another movie that we think is as
good as the ones that we've done and and
that was really our criteria for making
this one Matt worked out like a madman
to get into Jason Bourne shape and his
diet was brutal when you hit 45 it gets
hard to hit the gym two-a-days just
vegetables is that the real deal
vegetables and protein yeah I mean a lot
of produce just no carbs how tough was
that brutal I mean I like to eat man I I
you know my favorite thing is you know a
big bowl of pasta and a glass of red
wine man and been my friends around it
the director he said like if the movie
starts and you look like you've been
living well because we don't have a
movie Bravo yeah we're allowed to do
this here you guys so now I go for the
trips if you want to if you feel like
you feel president this is gonna go it's
gonna go well
Matt's no stranger to Vegas he was here
for the oceans films and now Jason
Bourne you think that Matt would be a
tough mark at the tables I've never been
luckier than when you've been sitting
here I'm glad I thought this was all
play money but I'm glad to see you're
feeling
is been really your best friend yeah I
mean we grew up together I mean yeah
best friend is kind of a children's
concept I am here to mately but I've
known him for 35 years you know we grew
up together we both were in love with
with acting and filmmaking and that that
bonded us for life by there did you set
these up man look I was magic right here
that is greatest hand of the day I want
a lot of money this is not listening now
for tax reasons I can't tell you how
much I won but I do want to say it was
weird because I'm sitting in the casino
with Matt Damon and nobody's looking up
because they're so busy gambling yeah
but that is Vegas they're concentrating
on everything else that's a guy the
weight you're buying me dinner tonight
oh I will winner Matt was great